the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
we turn today to Alfred Hitchcock one of
the most remarkable if not the most
remarkable and significant of what we
might call the great studio directors
the people who worked with great ease
and success inside the studio system
that developed in the United States
began to develop in the United States in
in more than embryonic form in early
systematic form in the silent era and
then was fortified and extended into the
great manufacturing mass manufacturing
center for dreams and movies the
Hollywood system of the studio of the
studio era and I wanted to begin by
saying a word about Hitchcock in
relation to that great system if we
think about a famous quotation from the
great film scholar pioneering film
critic Andre Bazin to whom we will
return later in the semester
buzzer is among his other influential
comments this one is a particularly
powerful and significant one the
American cinema he said wrote in 1957 is
a classical art and it's gun clear
exactly what he meant by that but most
most critics assume that what he meant
by that is that it's a system that works
according to essentially classical genre
forms that that that these genre forms
have origins behind the movies and that
the and that the system works in a kind
of generic way and that at least that's
a part of what he meant when he called
it a classical art the American cinema
is a classical art but why not then
admire it in what in what is most
admirable not only the talent of this or
that filmmaker but the genius of the
system I think I alluded to this phrase
or use this phrase earlier in the term I
want to do justice to it by
acknowledging its origins in Android but
there's also a wonderful book by a film
scholar from Texas named Tom Schatz
called the genius of the system and it
borrows it uses this quotation as its as
its inspiration and it's in an a
systematic analysis of the Hollywood
studio system
in which it talks about the interaction
of individual agency that writers the
directors the camera people and so forth
the costumers the interaction of those
creative or semi creative figures with
the with the manufacturing and publicity
practices and rituals that surrounded
the production of movies lucy tries to
provide a kind of integrated sense of
how the system worked to explore what
person apparently meant when he talked
about the genius of the system well one
way of understanding the genius of the
system is to recognize that it creates
an environment
first of all of stability in which
particular filmmakers or particular
writers or directors can have confidence
sometimes overwhelming confidence
because they're ordered to do the job by
the studio head can have confidence that
the that the genre stories they're
they're creating have an audience and of
course that's been sort of established
by the essentially assembly line system
that develops and the elaborate system
of distribution and access that
developed in the United States the major
studios actually although they only
controlled something like 16 percent of
the resources they of moviemaking
actually controlled a much larger
percentage of the theaters because many
of the theaters either were owned
outright by mate studios or until a
certain point one that in a Supreme
Court decision divested the studios from
forced the studios to divest themselves
from their theatrical holdings but when
when the system was in place it was a
monopoly system in which the rich got
richer in some sense in the major
studios controlled owned many theaters
themselves and and by a system of what
was called block booking by they forced
theaters not just to book particular
films and particular stars that they
might like but MGM would say to theatre
independent theater owners if you want
the MGM films you have to take my whole
card you can't just choose the Clark
Gable movies you have to choose the
whole thing and this stability created
an environment in which in which each
student each major studio was confident
that it had a that it affected had a
captive market for its product and
an immense sense of stability and
confidence when the system was working
at its best and what so that what and of
course again because it was a system
that was committed to entertaining the
largest number of people that it could
reach as possible it meant that there
were certain parameters that were
established within which the the entire
system was forced to operate whatever
genre was involved there were certain
kinds of limits it's what I was talking
about earlier
but trying to get at this aspect of the
system earlier when I talked about the
idea of consensus narrative if the
Hollywood film is reaching out to the
whole of the society and it's telling
essentially a story that appeals to or
is supposed to embody the consensus view
of the largest general view of what the
belief system of the of the society is
what that means is that there are limits
very short constraints political and
moral constraints within which the text
operates and as you know especially if
you've been reading your cook the
introduction of a particular sensory
system introduced by Hollywood itself in
order to avoid other kinds of censorship
perhaps on the government further
constrained the kinds of stories that
could be could be told well within those
constraints of course as I hope I've
already begun to show you you know in
our discussion of screwball comedy there
can be an immense range of of difference
but it's still within certain controlled
parameters and one of the ways to
understand
Hitchcock's immense success is to
recognize that he had the kind of
sensibility the kind of the kind of
artistic impulses and maybe even the
kinds of limitations that made the
studio system a kind of perfect
environment for him anyone who's looked
at a Hitchcock more than one or two
Hitchcock films is aware of the fact
that there's something obsessional
something deeply disturbing about
Hitchcock's imagination he's drawn again
and again and again to the same kinds of
situations to scenes of violence against
women to scenes of confinement but the
studio system was a kind of perfect
environment for this kind of for these
kinds of preoccupations on the one hand
the constraints of the system did not
allow Hitchcock even if he had the
impulse to do so to press so far into
the perversity and disturbance that is
the general subject matter
he is looking at as to actually fall
into say pornography or or or to or or
to fall into something that will deeply
offend some segment of the population we
can see that these were impulses in
Hitchcock's imagination though because
after the Hitchcock lasted long enough
live for such a long time he was he was
a successful director in the silent era
then he worked in Britain during the
sound era and was was was the most
well-known and successful of all British
directors in the early sound era then in
1940 he came to the United States for
what most people recognize as his
American phase he immigrated to the
United States and and and that that's a
separate kind of distinct part of his
career as I'll describe more in a little
more detail in a moment
well when he by the end of his career
Hollywood itself was undergoing profound
changes for reasons we've already begun
to talk about in this course and the
most important of them having to do
being the advent of television and the
way in which through the 1950s
television began to leech away the
consensus audience and the consensus
function that Hollywood had played in
American life and the effect of this was
to in some sense liberate Hollywood and
we'll be talking about what this
ambiguous liberation later in the course
when we look at some of the great films
that emerge in the 1970s that are free
of the constraints of a consensus system
films like McCabe and mrs. Miller or
cabaret the two films that were going to
be looking at later that embodied these
these sort of post studio era ideals and
principles well one of the ways in which
you can see the damage that was the the
help that was given to Hitchcock's own
imagination by what I'm calling the
genius of the system is that at we can
see that Hitchcock's late but that the
latest films that Hitchcock make the
films that Hitchcock makes at the very
end of his career and especially a film
two films a film called frenzy starring
Michael Caine in 1972 and the last film
that Hitchcock made in 1976 called
family plot the same basic materials but
to something gratuitous about the nudity
in these he wasn't allowed to show
nudity in the in the studio here and it
was good for his imagination and when
his imagination and any any honor
I need any honest viewer of Hitchcock
watching frenzy or especially family
plot and watching this there's a scene
in frenzy in which in which a murderer
strangles a woman now there have been
strangulation is one of Hitchcock's
favorite forms of murder
and there have been many characters
strangled in Hitchcock's movie but this
strangulation has a pornographic
dimension to it that none of the early
scenes like that and it has to do with
the fact that Hitchcock is now working
in a film environment that is not
telling him that he can't go too far and
he does go too far and there's a
terrible scene in which a man a murderer
takes off his tie and he strangles this
woman with a tie the woman is naked from
the waist up and you see her breasts
bobbling around on the screen while
she's being strangled and you can see
that the camera is enjoying the looking
looking at those breasts even even
though it's a scene of murder it's a
very very horrible scene a very
disturbing scene it's a scene that it
made it almost is a scene that makes you
believe in censorship to think that
censorship ought to be certainly you
wouldn't want young people to see this
scene the only reason that Hitchcock was
free to make to create this scene is
that there were no longer the same
constraints being imposed upon him by
what I want to call the constraining
genius of the system so my point is that
Hitchcock wasn't a man of obsessional
genius of a certain sort but he had the
great good fortune to work within a
system that also and limited his his
liabilities that didn't even allow the
full expression of his obsessions in
ways in ways that might that might
become deeply disturbing to audiences
the fact of the matter is when you look
at that scene and then you think back
and many earlier Hitchcock movies you
can see many equivalents of it violence
and damage to women is a recurring
obsession in Hitchcock Hitchcock is a
sick man in many ways but he's not a
sick artist he's a sick person he turns
his sickness into art he turns his
sickness into use by dramatizing it and
reminding us of the death though insofar
as he's a good filmmaker he's not the a
he's not a horrible perv right but but
there are perverted dimensions to hitch
guy defect part of why we find him
interesting is his films are always
hovering on the brink of awakening in us
feelings that are disturbing and
unsettling and that that touch on deep
taboos in the in the ways in which our
culture sort of understands how we
should behave and especially in our
attitudes toward our attitudes towards
sexuality and and and and and toward the
and towards seeing toward the act of
seeing which in Hitchcock becomes a kind
of wire ISM so one way to understand
Hitchcock is to understand his genius
his greatness as a director as being
directly connected to the fact that for
the most part of his career he worked in
systems that constrained him he worked
in systems that had very sharp
boundaries that didn't allow him to do
certain kinds of things and those
limitations were turned into artful and
and valuable gestures an anecdote that
Hitchcock told about himself many times
it's deeply revealing anecdote it may
not be true we're not really sure but he
told it so many times that it's true
even if it didn't happen that's a line
it's true even if it didn't happen it's
a line from Ken Kesey's wonderful novel
One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest and and
the character the the narrator in the
book the host sort of a crazy man we
think he's in an insane asylum he's in a
loony bin when he starts narrating the
story tells us a story of his
confinement in a lunatic asylum and he
says you think the man who's saying this
is Raven and crazing my god this is true
even if it didn't happen and what he
means is there's a kind of emotional
truth in it even if the actual facts
aren't true and I think that's true of
the Hitchcock anecdote as well and this
is the anecdote he said he he repeatedly
told about himself he said when he was a
young boy five or six years old he
committed some indiscretion that his
father disapproved of and his father in
response without saying anything to the
boy wrote a note sealed it in an
envelope gave it to the boy and said
told him to take it down to the local
constable the policeman and in the
police station around the corner from
where they lived in London no the young
boy dutifully took the note to him and
that gave it to the constable and
Constable opened it read it and locked
the boy in a prison cell and kept him in
there for a certain short amount of time
and then finally released him and said
this is what happens to
to to bad boys and Hitchcock has said
ever since then I have gone to any
lengths to avoid arrest and to avoid
confinement in confining spaces and in
fact if you think about it for a second
over and over again in Hitchcock's films
the a basic story not the only story but
a basic story he tells us the story of
someone who is wrongly accused we might
call it the wrong man thing right and
someone was on the run who looked at the
the circumstantial evidence against him
is over or her usually him is
overwhelming right absolutely looks and
all the authorities all their legitimate
authorities of the culture think the
this the the protagonist of the
Hitchcock chase film is guilty right and
his obligation is to somehow not only
escape the authorities who are much more
powerful and than he of course and have
out there but they're just at at their
fingertips all kinds of modern systems
for for for searching and following and
capturing people and the the the
fugitive is a lone fugitive on his own
without resources right and without
allies so he's up against tremendously
difficult forces and these are the
forces of legitimate Authority right so
the theme of the wrong man who's wrongly
acute the audience knows that he's
wrongly accused often jitka will show
the real murder and motion and will show
us how circumstantially persuasive but
also falsely evidence is so through the
most of the movie we identify with the
fugitive with the person who's running
we know he is it he is innocent so what
part of it is so many of his films then
sort of dramatize a kind of massive
principle of injustice that happens
again again in his movies authorities
are almost always after the wrong man so
and then and then many of his films and
overwhelming an overwhelmingly
disturbing recurring element in his
films is confinement in in tight spaces
is the sense of being caught and you'll
see one of the great great instances of
this one of his one one of his most
artistic accountings of this impulse
this fear of confinement but this
fascination with confined in the great
film you're going to see
rear window which takes place entirely
in a single confined space in a room
because the man who the protagonist has
a broken leg at the beginning of the
film and he's literally unable to move
out of his apartment so the entire film
is confined there and of course many of
Hitchcock's films love this so what is
it what an interesting anecdote to be
told when thinking and think by
implication what it says about his
father well not to mention what it says
about Hitchcock himself to have been
telling a story like to tell a story
like this so many times over the whole
of his career but the idea that a world
that seems perfectly benign and
protective could suddenly turn menacing
and terrible that behind any door or
window lurks some monstrosity that the
ordinary world is just a is just a
delusion that what you think of as
ordinary and plain and prosaic can
suddenly erupt in violence or in terror
or in or in or in the audience or in
some form of unpredictable assault is a
constant feeling you have in Hitchcock's
films is he his films his films dance
along an edge in which the whole of the
universe could be said to be in some
sense endangered the basic laws of our
experience in even even though even
sometimes the physical laws of our
experience are are upended or denied or
or or suspended in Hitchcock's world can
you think of one example where the laws
of nature itself suddenly go cuckoo one
of his most famous films the birds of
course the late film the birds what
happens in the birds yes the most benign
and beautiful parts of nature suddenly
begin to attack human beings and here
you give some partial explanation in the
film where you see there's a scene in a
restaurant where you see pictures of
what fried chicken and people talking
about how they love roast pheasant and
so forth but as if as if that's an but
in all of Hitchcock's films there there
is never an adequate a truly adequate
motive for the Magnussen terror disorder
that is released in the movies there's
often an attempt to explain them but
nobody takes me explanations very
seriously because the point is his
vision of life is a vision in which the
world is an incredibly dangerous wholly
unpredictable monstrously fearsome place
maybe his dominant emotion is the
emotion
fear he dramatizes fear over and over
and over again in his movies here is a
brief selection this he made over 50
films and I think 53 total films silent
and sound films in his career this is
just the list I put up there is just a
very brief selection but let me say a
few things about the the the trajectory
of that career and then and then I'll
turn to a little bit more about his
technical behavior about his about his
technical genius and about the central
themes of his work which I've already
begun to elaborate and won't won't
repeat myself too much I hope but let's
talk a bit about his career because he's
a very like the other like like Howard
Hawks and Frank Capra Hitchcock is maybe
even more than those two a figure of the
a dominant figure of the studio era
maybe the dominant figure certainly the
director whose work has been most
influential has lasted the longest one
of the most interesting things about
Hitchcock's career as a whole is that
for even after film came to be
recognized as something more than mere
entertainment Hitchcock was always
admired as a great entertainer and was a
successful director from them from from
the sound era from the silent era from
the time he began to work in Great
Britain when he made his move to the
United States just in in the Lyne 1939
he was Britain's most famous and most
admired director in fact when he came to
the United States there was a kind of
negative reaction in Britain because
because they felt it was unpatriotic of
this great director to desert his date
of homeland in the middle of the war
among other things and they and and he
did and there there he didn't feel guilt
over this in many ways and some of that
guilt is said by some scholars to
express itself in some aspects of the
other film you're going to see this
evening an earlier film made in 1943 but
shortly after Hitchcock had come to the
United States it wasn't his first
american film while he was making that
film he was receiving news from england
about his mother who was very ill and
she actually died during the me while he
was in the United States filming a
shadow of a doubt and
and and there are some scholars who say
that his familial feelings his guilt
over leaving England his guilt about
deserting his mother come out in various
ways in shadow of a doubt I'm not so
sure about that because that's a pretty
cynical and tough minded an anti
sentimental film in its own way but
there are some elements of family life
in it that perhaps
recover or allude to things aspects of
Hitchcock's own career one significant
thing ever as I've already suggested is
that he was successful at every phase of
in the history of movies that like hawks
and Capra he began in the silent era the
distinguished work there moved into the
sound era and distinguished work in the
in the sound here he has something else
in common with hawks and Capra and I
only recently discovered this it's not
as systematic as in the case of Hawks on
camera but he too studied engineering so
and there must be something in this you
guys should maybe reconsider what you're
what you're up to here because three of
the most remarkable and technically
adept directors in the history of the
state of the studio era all had
partially trained at partial training as
engineers so he begins in this in the
silent era and in fact he be he lets go
behind let me say just a little bit
about his background he was an outsider
in a certain way even though he was an
Englishman because he was a Jesuit his
parents were Catholic in Protestant
England and he felt himself all his life
I think in some ways to be a kind of
outsider someone who didn't exactly fit
in in in in in traditional society he he
went to work after his schooling in the
advertising department of a telegraph
company began to write the title cards
for silent films as early as nineteen
twenty one and then began before this
telephone Telegraph Company began to
work on it on certain features feature
films that were produced in Germany and
this is of course the great period of
German Expressionism when the great
German silent directors are are creating
their science fiction and expressionist
works and
Hitchcock in his early life is immersed
in that stuff learns that stuff goes to
school in that and you can feel the
expressionist impulse in the darkness
and the disturbance that's a central
part of almost every Hitchcock film he
he makes something like I think a total
of six or seven silent films of which of
which the do we have the list up there
yes of which the most important is the
The Pleasure Gardens was a co-production
the first film that he worked on
systematically and it was a German
co-production he wasn't the prime
director in the lodger is probably his
mom almost surely his most important and
most Hitchcockian silent film can you
guess the topic it's Jack the Ripper
it's a story it's a silent film it's a
story it's a story about a landlady who
thinks fearfully nervously that she may
have rented a room to Jack the Ripper
the famous killer so he's a successful
silent director already an admirer
director makes the transition to sound
and in fact historically he'd be famous
just for this one fact blackmail a
British film he made in 1929 is the
first British talkie and he almost
immediately began to begin to figure out
how to integrate it was very interested
in all at all the technical aspects of
moviemaking especially interested in the
way you integrate sound with image and
as anyone who's watched the the shower
scene in psycho for example would be a
famous example anyone who's watched
these scenes like that in his cup will
recognize the tremendous importance of
music in his films the way he uses music
to to deepen and complicate and the the
the moods he's creating and especially
how we can use mute music to enhance
your sense of terror and fear as he does
in certain frenzied powerful scenes in
his most remarkable films and then he
goes on to a really an immensely
successful career as the director of
action adventure mystery films of which
I've listed the most famous and
significant ones films that are still
interesting to people that are still
watched today for their own intrinsic
excitement even though they also many of
them also feel a bit old
in their in their behavior the man who
knew too much the 39 steps and The Lady
Vanishes
and there are other films he made in
this year I'm only listening a selection
as I've said then he makes the
transition to the United States he's
lured here by David Selznick they direct
the head of a great studio Hitchcock is
especially drawn to coming to the United
States because he envies the technical
resources that are available to American
director so because they have that much
more budget they can do much more when
they when they have enough when they
have enough money to add cameras and to
have adequate crews and so forth and the
first film he makes in the United States
Rebecca a remake of a famous novel won
an Academy Award as best film of the
year although Hitchcock did not win a
Director's Award but it's the least
Hitchcockian of all of his films and
perhaps he was restraining himself a
little bit in a in an attempt to
establish himself in the American or in
the American audience it's a very
interesting film and you can still see
that it in some Broadway fits Hitchcock
it's a gothic story the classic English
novels about governesses who go to off
in the country to strange mansions and
there they are both they are both
attracted to and repelled by the
handsome sometimes scarred stranger who
runs the place right I'm talking
especially about who what novel Jane
Eyre right Charlotte brontë's great
novel and of course that pattern that
got that pattern repeats itself again
and again in the movies and Rebecca is a
version of that kind of of that kind of
story and then Hitchcock goes on in the
40s to make a series of films in which
his own interest in the technology of
motion pictures and his own obsession
with sitting problems for himself that
are difficult to solve his own sort of
Engineers obsession with the technology
of motion picture begins to become
clearer and clearer one of the another
reason that the lodger is an important
Hitchcock film is that it's the first
film in which Hitchcock himself makes a
brief cameo appearance and after that it
becomes a kind of signature feature of
his movies then at some point in the
film a character Alfred Hitchcock with
will it will appear briefly won't be
identified he won't be noticed in the
credits but as he became more and more
well-known
audiences began to watch for this right
this bothered him in some way because it
meant they distracted them people from
the movies from the movies themselves
because they were waiting to see when
hitch would emerge so he began to do it
earlier and earlier in the films in
order to avoid distracting audiences but
think what it means having to devise a
way for him to be in the movie in many
cases it's easy okay a man's getting on
a bus so he can be in the crowd of the
but what happens when he makes films
that are arbitrarily restricted as he
does in some cases for example the film
lifeboat in 1944 some of you know about
it
it takes place entirely on a lifeboat
there are eight or nine characters
they've they've escaped the wreck it's
of world war ii parable about Nazism and
they're all stuck in the lifeboat and
for the entire film well the the film is
confined to that lifeboat I mean it
presents all kind it's not one of his
best films but it's but the technical
challenge presented is really
interesting isn't it
vertigo is an even more interesting
instance and a much more successful
instance of the same desire or the same
weird impulse in in Hitchcock himself to
create confining situations and then see
what that confinement allows him to do
what what what grows out of these
arbitrary these arbitrary limitations
but just as a kind of minor instance of
this kind of thing if all the characters
in in lifeboat are on a on a are on a
boat in the middle of the ocean
how can Hitchcock appear because he's
not one of the main characters does
anyone know how he did it he has it
there's a newspaper lying on the floor
of the boat and you pick up the
newspaper there's a picture of Hitchcock
in the newspaper but it's a trivial
thing right but it should be anybody but
it's it's triviality is exactly what
makes it so interesting in other words
what Hitchcock loved this kind of
problem when he made when he took these
problems in a serious way and when these
problems sort of led him into a kind of
exploration of our darker and more
disturbed and more uncivilized sides he
made remarkable films that's that there
are that are memorable and haunting
right and one more example of him said
of the of Hitchcock sitting himself
these
technical feats the film rope
well titled in a way it's a murder
mystery but Hitchcock set it up in a way
it's it's actually such that it creates
the illusion that the entire film I
don't remember how long it is let's say
it's a standard feature-length film
let's say it's 89 minutes long it's a
standard feature-length film it feels as
if it's all unraveled in a single take
as if there are no cuts no edits in the
movie now it's not exactly true what
because the film was not capable
technically of doing that what Hitchcock
did was he had cassettes of that would
move that were of a film that would last
say 10 minutes so he would make
10-minute long takes but then he'd have
to change the cassette put in a new one
but he disguised the takes he disguised
the cuts and in fact it's an
unbelievably tedious film and because
when you're watching it you feel you
can't look away one of the things that
is this good that you discover when
you're watching this film is that cuts
are actually a relaxation they let you
relax they they breaks they break the
rhythm in some way and if you sit there
for 89 minutes watching something that
seems to be unfolding and then film of
course unfolds in real time also they're
right so it's so so he's playing both
with another kind of confinement which
is the duration of the movie he's saying
I'm going to make the duration of the
viewing the same duration of the action
of the movie and I'm never going to
Carter I'm going to create the illusion
that there's not going to be a single
edit in my film when you're watching it
you actually yourself feel trapped you
feel you feel guilty if you look away or
you but you constantly want to blink or
look down because this some it's almost
as if the absence of edits creates a
kind of continuous stream of imagery and
you feel you're trapped wouldn't it like
a wall that doesn't let you escape from
it well though that kind I don't know
that Hitchcock actually intended such a
reaction but it is not inconsistent with
Hitchcock's desire to manipulate your
feelings as you're watching a film and
he became a master at manipulating your
reactions as you as you watch the film
so there are many and I could I could
cite many other examples of this sort of
technical obsession but let me just say
a couple of things about the major films
in so he and he's successful in
everything
but he really comes into his own most
critics would say at the end of the
1940s with a series of maybe the early
50s with a series of films that run from
51 through maybe most people would say
through the birds in 1963 and I haven't
listed all the films he made in that era
but I've listed the most important ones
and if you can judge for yourself how
significant this is why because look at
how many titles you recognize how many
titles by directors of so many years ago
would you actually have seen it's one
measure of what an important figure what
a successful figure Hitchcock is that
that he's still so widely known that
he's more famous today than he was when
he was making his movies as I started to
say earlier one of the most distinctive
things or interesting and revealing
things about Hitchcock's career is that
through the men through the mass of his
career even though he was one of the
most popular directors and his films
made money and he was he was a totally
bankable director noted them maybe the
most bankable director in Hollywood
during the studio era he didn't get much
respect part some people have suggested
that one of the reasons for is that he
gave so much pleasure that there was a
feeling that anyone who gave this much
pleasure couldn't be an artist but that
that that it worked against him that he
would that he was such a great
entertainer and there may be something
to that but steadily over time and
especially since his death his
reputation has increased and increased
increased and in fact recently his film
vertigo was voted the best film of all
time the best film ever made displacing
Orson Welles Citizen Kane which had been
at the top of this list for something
like 20 years and this ascension from in
which Hitchcock was sort of denigrated
as a mere entertainer to now being
recognized as one of the greatest
artists of in the movies of the 20th
century is a very interesting
development and it's a development
that's partly a function of the fact
that all of that happened after the
movies were no longer the central
experience in in in America the central
narrative experience in in the modern
world in which they had already been
placed as a as a as a as a system so in
this period between the strangers on a
train through the birds in 1963 some
people might include Marnie in 64 he
made a series of masterpieces that are
among the most significant and most
powerful films ever made two of which
we're talking about tonight
Hitchcock the technician I've already
implied something about this but it's
worth emphasizing this Hitchcock became
Hitchcock became famous especially in
the industry for the unbelievably
fastidious almost bored way in which he
carried out his direction of a movie by
the time Hitchcock got to the set of the
film he had so obsessively planned out
every aspect of the movie that that he
acted as if everything was all finished
as any any he he often annoyed his
actors some actors disliked him a lot
because he gave very little instruction
to his actors and so some some actors
like this but many many resented it a
great deal he see he is often quoted as
a he's been quoted a number of times as
showing a kind of disregard for actors
at one point he said actors are just
cattle to be moved around on the set
like animals but but but it was more the
fact that the actors had trouble with
him because he seemed to have worked
everything out before he got to the set
he was always tremendously calm he sat
in his director's chair would give
directions and he had storyboarded he
had drawn out every single scene and
every single camera angle before he even
came to the set so that it was as if he
had worked everything out before he
reached the set and and what that meant
of course is that no improvisation on
the set he would be very unhappy if
people try to deviate never allowed
people to deviate from the plans that
had been set before this is in shocking
contrast to the per to the way in which
let's say a director like Jean Renoir or
sometimes Orson Welles might operate in
making their film quite the looking for
the contingent and the accidental that
happens while you're at work creatively
Hitchcock would have none of that
Hitchcock came into the process of
directing with the film finished
completed in his head completely
fastidiously blocked angled and so forth
and there was no deviation from it and
he actually did often act bored when he
did it but how interesting that so he
but he's also of course a supreme
technician of the movies a master of
camera angle a master of montage a
master of the mingling of love of music
and image right and and and you'll see
many many examples of this in the two
films we are going to see this evening
how interesting them that he is this
incredibly fastidious granular
technician who plans out every single
camera angle before he comes on the set
what does this tell us why would he do
that what's interesting about it what's
most revealing about it why would
someone do this maybe if the subject
matter you're trying to deal with this
so on ruling and so frightening that the
only way you could handle it is by
surrounding it with this pretense of
fastidious coherence and control and I
think that there's no question at all
that his cool demeanor his mocking
demeanor and especially his sense when
he comes to make the actual make the
film to actually make the film that all
the problems have been solved that
everything has already been done is an
attempt to compensate for or defend
himself against the roiling irrational
power of the subject matter that his
films mobilize what a wonderful
revealing paradox right he's this
fastidious technician and he's but his
themes are the themes of craziness of
madness of murder of wire ISM of
violence of rape of strangulation of
fear of pursuit imprisonment confinement
injustice one of the most interesting
things about history activity and those
of you who see more than two or three of
his films will feel this much more
strongly than those of you have only
seen a few of them is how over how
essentially passive deeply unaggressive
and acted upon most of his protagonists
are they're being pursued they're on the
run they're confined in small places
they're full of fear one of Hitchcock's
recurring moments a recurring scene is a
is
the protagonists dangling from a height
you'll see one magnificent instance of
this at the end of rear window where
Jimmy Stewart is hanging like this above
a void and you see his face and you can
see his face register abject fear right
we could call that one of Hitchcock's
iconic moments it occurs again and again
in his movies characters hanging over a
void terrified terrified of what of what
of what is about to happen and often
they fall into the void
there are Eamon and his and some of the
dream sequences in Hitchcock are show us
cactus falling through voids into
nothingness
so the subject matter of Hitchcock's
films
couldn't be more shocking and disturbing
in some sense they mobilize problematic
subjects that are terrifying and they
obviously were so terrifying to
Hitchcock that his only way of dealing
with them was to surround them with all
this appearance of control
another thing that follows from this and
it's a very one final point to make
about itch Cox films is how often is
reassuring our happy endings don't
reassure or make us happy and the reason
of course is that he doesn't mean the
happy endings I'll come back to this
again but very often he even though his
films fit them perfectly within with or
imperfectly but well enough into the
convention that the endings of a in a
consensus system that the endings of
these stories afterwards some sense
restore normality and reassure us
Hitchcock goes through the motions of
doing that but again and again the
endings of his films are morally
ambiguous and and provide us with kind
of subtext which put in question the
reassurance that we have superficially
been offered as if there's a kind of as
if there's a level of irony and cynicism
and deconstructive contempt beneath
undermining the reassurance that the
endings that the endings offer us and
and that's also a part of this of this
idea that the themes that that Hitchcock
mobilizes are that are the dark elements
of our subconscious and of our
unconscious and of the
and and the fear that people have fear
of Authority fear of disorder fear of
disturbance a sense that the ordinary
world is full of Menace and terror but
again and again in Hitchcock's films he
doubles his characters and you'll have a
good character in an evil character the
idea he grew up in the era of Robert
Louis Stevenson dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde
and he actually thought that was a
version of human psychology that there's
a kind of dark or savage aspect in
ourselves that's hidden or damped down
by civilization and if we if we could
let it come out we could turn monstrous
we could turn horrible and and again and
again in Hitchcock's films we have a
kind of doubling in which one character
interacts with with a more villainous or
murderous character who come who we come
to recognize as a kind of double of the
protagonist who represents the darker
more disturbing energies within the
protagonists nature right and in
strangers on a train what happens a guy
pops a tennis star who's having trouble
with his wife is on a train and a guy
pops up next to him and says I know
you're having trouble with your wife I'd
rather better the newspaper let's make a
deal nobody can track us it'll be the
perfect murder I'm having trouble with
my wife you murder my wife and I'll
murder yours look the guy said we gotta
get thee behind me Satan right don't
ever talk to me again I'm very nervous
about it a few weeks later his wife is
murdered and then he starts getting
messages from this guy when are you
going to fulfill your part of the
bargain right that's what the film is
about right but it's a wonderful
interesting movie the scene I want you
to see now a dramatized is some of this
and this is a Menendez of the great
climax of the film and one reason I want
you to see it is that it also shows
another aspirin another aspect of his
what we might call sort of the world of
the thematic world of Hitchcock's films
and it's it's his it's his recurring
interest in the subject of entertainment
itself what he became aware of and what
his films often dramatize is the illicit
and disturbing dimension of our desire
to go to the movies or of our desire to
have the kinds of excitements we get
when we go to amusement parks what
shikaka understood was that these
experiences have an illicit dimension we
sit in the dark and what do we do when
we sit in the dark we watch people take
their clothes off we watch the murder
each other
we're Sikh we're in the dark we're safe
nobody know we're solitary we're
anonymous but we're what our voyeurs
were and what he understood was that
wire ism was at the heart of going to
the movies was look the heart of the
movie experience and if they will we'll
come back to this we'll come back to
this scene so at the end of strangers on
a train there's a particularly wonderful
and dramatic example of Hitchcock
looking at the space of entertainment as
a space that can turn into an
environment of menace and disturbance
and this is character and and again
exactly because remember I said one of
his deep themes is what might we might
call the Menace of the ordinary well
what could be more ordinary and
reassuring than a child's merry-go-round
but here's the great climax of strangers
on a train in which the good and the bad
the good and the evil sides have to do a
kind engage in a kind of contest or
wrestling match and as you're watching
note the way in which characteristic of
Hitchcock characteristic of him there's
a combination of terror and comedy he he
unsettles us also because the most often
the most terrifying scenes are leavened
with a kind of macabre comedy that
unsettles us even more here's the scene
good guy bad guy you finally see this in
trouble these are very helpful FBI
people who do more harm than good
then they shoot at the wrong person to
begin with and they actually
accidentally shoot the person who's
controlling the merry-go-round so it
goes out of control
part of the comedy here is they're wrong
they don't know who they're talking
about they have the wrong man but we in
the audience know it
the only hitch could have such
confidence that he could introduce a
comic moment like that in the middle of
what is a terrifying climax the only
director would do that regularly
now you know the bad guys right so the
hero rescues the kid
is this a montage or a muse onsen effect
a montage effect right see the close-up
on the animal the way you get very with
the camera itself doesn't allow you to
sort of look back and get a sense of the
environment your your emotions are
controlled by the tightness of the shot
by the quickness of the editing
comic version of a hero right
and this is quintessential Hitchcock are
we saved
very helpful
all right that's an you get the idea so
the fact the fact that this space of
entertainment we get lights up the fact
that this space of entertainment could
become a straight one more minute people
could become a space of terror is the
point so finally what would we say about
Hitchcock he's a double man to borrow
from the great essayist Montaigne who
said I we are we human beings are I know
not how
doubling ourselves so that what we
believe we disbelieve and cannot rid
ourselves of what we condemn what
Hitchcock tries to condemn or what
Hitchcock thinks he hates keeps coming
back in his films images of
strangulation of damage to women of
images of fear and and and and terror in
the face of irrational Authority these
key these themes keep returning again
and again in this film with the power of
obsession but he controls the obsession
with that fastidious technical distance
that allows these obsessions to reach us
in a way that disturbs and enlightens
you